bueno los misiles estos obviamente son
vehículos
autopropulsados que viajan a gran
velocidad no no tienen piloto
la velocidad es la clave son
hipersónicos porque viajan a varias
veces la velocidad del sonido quiere
decir que
un arte un avión supersónico vuela a
1.200 kilómetros o más una un vehículo
hipersónico viaja de tres o cuatro veces
más O sea tiene una gran velocidad lo
que distingue a estos estos misiles es
que no solo viajan a una gran velocidad
sino que esta velocidad la realizan
dentro de la zona de la atmósfera o sea
cerca de la Tierra y que con lo cual
tienen capacidad para modificar y
cambiar su trayectoria y básicamente no
hay defensa contra contra estos misiles
defensa aérea no es muy difícil o por
ahora es casi imposible interceptarlos
porque insisto viajar a mucha velocidad
a ras del suelo y saturan los este los
las defensas aéreas por ahora nos hemos
encontrado el antídoto